[Musique]
le rendez vous est donné à la chargeuse
de dijon chapeau melon sur la tête tout
de noir vêtu germa à feu 35 ans tient à
nous montrer le puits de moïse pourquoi
je le net vous l'expliquer
[Musique]
nous sommes ici dans l'ancienne
chartreuse de champmol devant le puits
de moïse qui est sans doute une des plus
belles sculptures de toute l'histoire de
l'art encore plus belle que le moïse de
michel-ange et ça nous donne un peu une
idée de ce que produisait la bourgogne à
l'époque où elle était libre mais à
l'époque des ducs c'est l'âge d'or de la
bourgogne et d'ailleurs il suffit de
regarder ici ce qui reste de la
chartreuse et ce qui a été construit
après on voit que la différence est
flagrante et que la chartreuse avait
quand même une supériorité par rapport
aux constructions modernes une passion
voire une nostalgie pour l'époque des
ducs de bourgogne
ce natif de semur-en-auxois la
découverte en quittant sa région natale
d'abord pour aller faire ses études en
sciences politiques à lyon puis pour son
travail de bibliothécaire à paris j'ai
découvert la différence entre reste de
la france et la bourgogne
j'ai pris conscience de la singularité
et surtout du charme la culture
bourguignonne après j'ai eu justement
envie de la défendre j'ai eu envie de la
faire connaître de la développer et puis
de le faire perdurer
d'où l'idée de créer le mouvement pour
la bourgogne libre et de le faire vivre
via un blog un mouvement qui revendique
dix adhérents et une centaine de
sympathisants du sérieux et du lourd
donc la preuve des articles dans la
presse locale mais aussi nationale
society france inter france info
une web tv d'extrême droite mais aussi
le site libertaire pro lgbt et anti
trust le vice le personnage est
inclassable politiquement et n'a pas
l'intention de se présenter aux
élections malgré un manifeste de
conditions
depuis vercingétorix jusqu'à charles le
téméraire la bourgogne a toujours refusé
la soumission à présent c'est à notre
génération qu'il appartient d'achever ce
combat de boucler la boucle et de faire
enfin de la bourgogne un état libre et
indépendant
ça c'est le signe de ralliement de son
mouvement
ainsi dès demain censé reprendre la
forme de l'escargot devant la statue
d'alexis piron un poète satirique du
xviiie siècle la démarche de
l'indépendantiste devient plus clair
nous avons écrit à ban ki moon que
l'époque où il était responsable de
l'onu défend d'ailleurs un peu le droit
des peuples à disposer d'eux mêmes
visiblement le peuple bourguignons ne
faisait pas partie de ses priorités
nous avons écrit aussi à barack obama
justement puisque ses statuts par
exemple a été détruite par les
bombardements américains pendant la
guerre alors de les avoir demandé une
petite contribution vent qu'il fût se
réparer les dommages qui avaient été
causées par les bombardements et il n'a
pas voulu dû rembourser le lait frais de
réparation de ses statuts après nous
avons demandé bien sûr aller pour lens
aux différents présidents président
nicolas sarkozy au président françois
hollande mais je sais pas le courrier a
dû s'égarer vous que je n'ai toujours
pas reçu leur réponse peut-être qu'un
jour
nous répondre et des indépendances il
avait demandé poliment germain fc bien
qu'il a peu de chance de connaître un
jour une bourgogne indépendante
mais comme disait charles le téméraire
point n'est besoin d'espérer pour
entreprendre ni de réussir pour
persévérer
[Musique]